as well we're on fire watch in the
southwest part of the valley on this
friday afternoon
as the fight continues to contain the
sandy valley fire
it burned more than 15-hundred acres a
few miles from mountain springs
south of highway 160. that is where we
find joe mohler with the latest on what
caused this fire joe
well christian this fire has been
burning for more than 24 hours now and
just a short time ago we learned
that law enforcement determined the
cause to be target shooting i'll give
you a live look
here at where this fire is burning along
this hillside not too far from mountain
springs
this has so far burned 1 500 acres is a
little bit of a different scene than
what we saw yesterday with all that
plume of smoke we have been seeing smoke
throughout the day and planes just
dropping off
fire retardant now crews are still
working on containment
throughout the day we have watched
tankers drop that retardant on the fire
and around it
small trees could be seen burning on the
hillside now yesterday this
sparked around 1 30 and later in the day
the plume of smoke was
easily visible from las vegas and
perhaps kirsten conner from the bureau
of land management says law enforcement
determined a bullet hitting a rock and
dry vegetation to be the cause
she says there are target shooting
restrictions
steel core ammunition is not allowed on
the unmanaged public lands
nor are explosive targets so near the
site where the fire
was started tannerite which is an
explosive target was found
no structures have burned crews are
working to stop the blaze from moving
north towards mountain springs now back
out here live you're taking a look at
just one of the helicopters we've been
watching
a drop of water and [ __ ] here on
this
hillside now every night fire crews
create a plan of attack for the next day
we are expecting the next update
uh regarding this fire and acreage
burned later on this evening around
eight o'clock but they say
uh take precautions because they do know
it's going to get hotter over the next
few days like you just heard ted
mention there so definitely something to
think about if you are heading out and
doing any sort of target practice or
anything like that i'll send it back to
you guys